ukraine's president vladimir zelinski
meanwhile has said high tensions with
russia are nothing new urging western
countries not to panic but the looming
threat of a russian attack means many
ukrainians are taking steps to stay safe
schools are preparing children for the
possibility of war
we visited one school in the capital
kiev where kids are learning about the
dangers that could be to come
deadly bombs munitions firearms
we are not in a military facility but a
school
mine awareness training for the kids at
school number 259 in the ukrainian
capital kiev
the kids are taught that explosives can
come in all shapes and sizes
it looks just like an ordinary soft toy
but it contains an explosive
and any contact picking it up touching
it or just walking by can set this off
the kids are curious all this is new to
them
armed conflict with russian-backed
separatists has been going on for years
but here in kiev the front line is far
away
but given the latest escalations the
school wants to be prepared
some of the staff have seen this before
history teacher olena jakov liver comes
from a town that is now
occupied we never thought we would need
this kind of knowledge
but then suddenly in june of 2014 the
kids were shot at on their way to school
we found out later it wasn't the army
but separatist fighters
and this became our daily reality
an alarm goes off meaning the building
has to be evacuated
this is just a drill but it's a
realistic scenario there have been
frequent bomb threats against schools in
recent weeks they were all false alarms
but worries about the safety of school
children in ukraine are growing
it's important to do this pupils who are
not here today will not know what to do
it's more interesting
everyone hopes the children won't need
to put their training into practice
but they have to be ready for the worst